bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir le budget de tous les
dangers dans les prochains jours le
gouvernement devrait dégainer le 49-3
sur le projet de loi de finances 2023
toute la question c'est quand avant ou
après la grande marche des insoumis
contre la vie chère de dimanche chaque
groupe politique affute sa stratégie et
en pleine crise des carburants et bien
la semaine qui s'ouvre dans l'hémicycle
s'annonce inflammable en témoigne
l'attention lors des questions au
Gouvernement vous le verrez on parle de
tout cela dans notre grand débat ce soir
avec nos invités dans un instant sur ce
plateau jalousie trahison cruauté
bienvenue dans l'univers impitoyable des
grandes familles françaises notre grand
témoin s'est plongé dans les coulisses
et les secrets des dynasties du
capitalisme français Bolloré Arnaud
Lagardère c'est doux succession chez
Albin Michel dépasse vous le verrez
largement la série américaine Raphaël
baquet signe cette enquête avec sa
consœur du monde Vanessa Schneider elle
sera sur ce plateau pour nous en parler
en deuxième partie enfin nous
affranchissent ce soir pour la politique
j'ai nommé Jean-Rémy Baudot quel avenir
pour l'encourant groupe d'amitié France
- Russie à l'Assemblée une nouvelle
histoire d'école de Yanis roder la
révolte iranienne vue de sa classe de
Seine-Saint-Denis et puis
l'international avec Vincent le jeu ce
soir la Biélorussie prête à entrer dans
la guerre de Poutine contre l'Ukraine
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
pour une fois on connaît à l'avance la
fin du film Le 49.3 mais pas forcément
les rebondissements pour y aboutir
bonsoir à tous on s'arrête ce soir sur
le débat budgétaire il a commencé hier
dans l'hémicycle 3300 amendements un
record qui promet quelques belles passes
d'armes à nouveau à l'image de ce qui
s'est passé aux questions au
Gouvernement cet après-midi on va y
revenir dans le détail bonsoir Thomas
Cazenave et bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes député Renaissance le parti
présidentiel député de Gironde et membre
de la commission des finances dans
laquelle vous siégé également
Marie-Christine Dalloz bonsoir et
bienvenue à vous député les républicains
du Jura les républicains semblent-ils un
peu divisé sur la stratégie sur ce texte
on en parlera certains la plupart la
grande majorité va voter contre mais
quelques-uns pourraient s'abstenir
bonsoir Damien Maudet et bienvenue à
vous vous êtes député la France
insoumise de hautes viennent enfin la
journaliste économique à l'opinion
Jacques Grandin de l’éprevier va nous
rejoindre parce qu'on a besoin de son
expertise sur ce budget tout ça c'est
après le billet de Blacko bien sûr
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à tous ce
comptoir à toutes si j'ai bien compris
le 49-3 on y va tout droit
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris Stéphane ce soir
j'ai bien compris ce que vous venez tout
juste de dire en fait Myriam le
gouvernement n'a pas le choix il va
devoir utiliser le 49-3 mais on se pose
quand même la question de savoir quand
va-t-il utiliser le 49 francs parce
qu'en principe le vote du budget enfin
cette première partie était programmée
le 25 octobre mais le gouvernement
va-t-il laisser l'opposition attaquer
son budget pendant 15 jours 15 longues
journées alors qu'il s'est déjà dès
maintenant que tous les groupes de
positions vont voter contre ce budget
c'est la question qu'on se pose ce soir
mais déjà hier manuel Bompard se la
posait à la tribune de l'Assemblée
où allez-vous passer en force peut-on
savoir Monsieur les ministres si le
débat que nous avons engagé ira jusqu'à
son terme ou si ce que nous engageons
est une simple comédie avant que le
couperait ne tombe alors à partir de
quand peut-il très juridiquement
concrètement dégainer le 49-3 alors il
faut une délibération en Conseil des
ministres mais ça tombe bien demain il y
a un conseil des ministres donc en fait
dès que Elisabeth bande de casse
autorisation elle peut utiliser 49
phrases c'est-à-dire même jeudi même
vendredi si elle a l'autorisation demain
donc ce qui plaiderait pour cet usage
ultra rapide du 49.3 c'est la crainte du
débat qui s'enlise parce que je le sais
bien l'opposition va nous lire la main
sur le cœur nous on veut débattre et
changer des arguments sauf que hier
quand même elle est fille a déposer un
projet voilà et vous avez tout à fait
raison et donc forcément Jean-René
Cazeneuve de la majorité était très
énervé en écoute
le président concret nous dit il y a
quelques minutes il ne faut pas de 49,3
il faut que le débat aille lieu et la
nuit pèse nous propose deux motions de
rejet qui auraient conséquence qu'il n'y
a absolument aucun débat où est la
cohérence
vous voyez que c'est animé l'Assemblée
en même temps c'est vrai que le 49-3
c'est le contraire du compromis c'était
le grand mot le mantra de la première
ministre ici
même pour on a tous nos petites
contradictions je vais vous dire voilà
on en est là cercle en théorie le
gouvernement vraiment un compromis en
fait un compromis où tout le monde
serait d'accord avec son budget sauf
qu'en pratique c'est évidemment très
différent que faire par exemple du côté
de la nupette on trouve que le budget
est très mauvais parce que c'est un
budget d'austérité on cherche à faire
beaucoup trop d'économies on écoute
Charlotte Leduc la seule boussole qui
guide la macronie c'est l'équilibre
budgétaire et la réduction de la dette
ainsi ce projet de loi ne se fixe qu'un
objectif planifier et organiser
l'austérité pour les 5 années à venir
afin de parvenir au sacro-saint déficit
de 3% du PIB à l'horizon 2027 oui mais
voilà le problème c'est qu'à droite
c'est exactement le contraire on est
d'accord sur un truc le budget est nul
ça ok mais pour des raisons différentes
c'est à dire qu'on ne fait pas assez
d'économies au contraire on écoute
Véronique louvagi républicaine le
problème c'est que ce budget 2023 ne
propose pour toute économie que des
pistes très hypothétiques le problème
c'est que cette dette abyssale qui pèse
sur nos enfants et nos petits-enfants
nous rend terriblement vulnérables et
pourrait menacer la pérennité de notre
modèle social si nous ne faisons rien
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on fait plus
de dépenses on fait plus d'économies
manifestement le compromis sera très
difficile à trouver d'où l'idée du
recours au 49-3 parce que là ça serait
vraiment très vite réglé le débat autant
on peut pas trouver de compromis s'il y
a pas de débat ça vous la mettrai coup
j'avoue Myriam là c'est vrai qu'après le
principe du compromis c'est de faire un
peu de débat mais imaginez ce qui va se
passer c'est des banni pendant 15 jours
les oppositions on sera tellement
réussir à faire voter des amendements
c'est déjà arrivé pendant que le texte a
été mission examiné en commission de
finances justement donc des événements
qui font des pensées plus que le
gouvernement va vouloir ensuite enlever
à la fin du débat parce que ça
correspond pas à son projet de budget
des amendements qui ont été de la
majorité des voix auprès des députés
donc ça devient quand même un peu gênant
non moi je vous dis le 49-3 un moment si
on vous écoute c'est c'est fait d'ici à
la fin de semaine c'est pas si c'est
fait mais il y a des gens qui se
remontés à l'Assemblée je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez d'Aurore berger la
semaine dernière quand elle s'en est
pris au groupe insoumis on sent bien
pour elle c'est
œil pour œil dent pour dent pas de
quartier envers nous bah pas de quartier
envers eux mais peut-être que le
gouvernement sera un peu plus prudent
sortir le 49.3 là juste avant la grande
manif de samedi est-ce que c'est pas
offrir un motif de mobilisation
supplémentaire à la gauche et à la nuit
pèse d'autant que la
donc voilà rien n'a changé c'est bien
dimanche excusez-moi je crois que ça ça
ira vous n'avez pas de démobiliser les
troupes pour cette erreur en plus de la
manif il y a bien sûr c'est c'est que
devant les stations essence et donc ce
débat la dactu s'est invité hier quand
on parlait du budget on écoute dying
Giraud et les filles le conflit social
en cours résume tout nos débats ici à
l'Assemblée c'est le conflit entre les
salariés et les actionnaires c'est le
conflit entre les salaires et les
dividendes et nous le disons ici pour ce
projet de loi de finances nous sommes
fiers d'être du côté des salariés et des
salaires pour vous dire que l'aptune est
vraiment pas absent du débat là on
parlait donc de la Manche de Dima la
marche de dimanche mais de son côté on
parle d'argent des fils d'essence devant
les stations mais lui Gabriel attaque
qui a été pris à parti a mis en cause la
marche de dimanche donc
et moi que vous expliquez que vous vous
opposez à tous les textes que nous
prenons pour le quotidien des Français
parce que vous préférez manifester c'est
ça votre solution quand est-ce qu'une
manifestation a rempli le frigo des
français quand est-ce qu'elle a fait
baisser une facture vous voyez c'est
beau le débat l'assemblée c'est
intéressant c'est animé on a envie que
ça dure mais combien de temps le
gouvernement va laisser la mer débat
c'était très complet ce soir merci
beaucoup
merci Stéphane Thomas Cazenave votre
sentiment député c'est votre première
mandat c'est intéressant de savoir
comment vous vous affrontez ce débat
budgétaire est-ce qu'il faut laisser du
temps au débat pour que ce débat
budgétaire s'installe dans la durée
est-ce que pour vous le 49-3 doit être
le dernier recours mais c'est ce qu'on
dit depuis le début d'ailleurs depuis
d'ailleurs les dialogues de Bercy les
ministres qui ont reçu les oppositions
on souhaite construire du compromis mais
la difficulté dans laquelle on s'est
trouvé c'est que avant même de connaître
le contenu de la proposition du projet
de budget les avait déjà annoncé qu’elle
va être contre rendant de ce fait
inéluctable le 49-3 vous pouvez le dire
publiquement il y aura un 49-3 bien sûr
qu'il y aura un moins que dans les dans
les heures qui viennent les oppositions
changent de position et accepte de
négocier nous c'est ce qu'on a fait
depuis le début de dimanche c'est frais
faire un cadeau aux insomnies nous
depuis les travaux en commission les
députés de la majorité on est prêt à y
consacrer toutes nos journées toutes nos
nuits à débattre défendre nos
propositions parce qu'on pense que c'est
un bon budget il y a des avancées
attendues pour les Français donc nous on
est dans cet état d'esprit depuis le
début mais en effet je veux dire les
oppositions annoncer la couleur très tôt
contre la vie du gouvernement ça c'est
une possibilité envisageable dans la
tête de la majorité mais la négociation
la négociation c'est quand même accepter
de faire des concessions faut-il qu'on
soit dans ce dans cet état d'esprit et
aujourd'hui manifestement aucun des
groupes de position n'est prêt à arrêter
le budget Damien Maudet
théorie est prête à faire des compromis
enfin moi je trouve ça incroyable quand
même comme débat de se dire évidemment
on va faire un 49-3 évidemment on va
passer en force pourquoi parce qu'on a
fait un texte qui n'acceptait par
personne mais on devrait pas se remettre
en question et on va passer en force
notre texte enfin quand même il y a un
sujet sur la forme sur la démocratie 45
milliards de boucliers tarifs faire sur
l'énergie c'est 22 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaire par rapport à 2022
priorité au service public éducation
travail justice défense et santé ça vous
convient pas
le bouclier non non mais là je parle
j'essaye de faire un petit
panorama rapide déjà pour les pour les
ménages au niveau de l'énergie puisque
avant c'est de l'eau qu'à 4 % maintenant
c'est 15%, ensuite on peut prendre un
sujet moi j'ai un exemple qui est très
concret sur la loi de programmation des
finances publiques donc où est-ce qu'on
veut aller au niveau de vos finances
publiques sur l'hôpital alors qu'on dit
que London donc l'objectif de dépenses
il faut augmenter de 4% par an ils ne
vont l'augmenter que de 2,6% par an à
partir de 2023 on sort de deux ans de
covid on a passé tous les thés aller
voir des soignants qui n'en pouvaient
plus des urgences qui ont fermé le
gouvernement nous amène sa copine nous
dit on va faire des économies sur
l'hôpital comme ce qui s'est passé
durant toutes les dernières années et
d'autant plus soit Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière on
apprenait encore qu'ils avaient fermé
4300 litres enfin moi je trouve ça
incroyable de se dire d'austérité vous
reprenez l'expression évidemment que
c'est un budget d'austérité mais enfin
au-delà non mais au-delà c'est obligé
d'austérité mais sur la forme parce que
je pense que c'est important quand même
sur la forme sur 49-3 comment on peut
entendre et aujourd'hui nous dire
normalement tous les groupes
d'opposition sont contre notre budget
donc on passe en force non c'est tous
les groupes de positions sont contre on
propose un nouveau budget et là c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui alors attendez on
va finir le tour de table et vous
répondrez Marie-Christine Dalloz vous
c'est le contraire c'est un budget trop
dépensier c'est bien ça il y a 62
milliards milliards d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires en 2023 dont les 17
milliards sur d'intérêts supplémentaires
sur la dette puisque vous n'êtes pas
sans ignorer que les taux d'intérêt
augmentent et que l'augmentation telle
qu'elle est programmée avec un taux
2,5%, va générer 2017 milliards de
d'euros d'intérêts supplémentaires je
parle pas du du reste on vend la France
va emprunter 200 milliards en 2023 quel
cadeau on va laisser à nos enfants et à
nos petits-enfants et à nos arrières
petits-enfants qu'est-ce que c'est que
ce monde où on veut tout aujourd'hui et
rien pour demain j'ai pas cette vision
là je suis désolé moi je pense aux
générations futures et j'ai pas envie de
leur laisser un sac à dos aujourd'hui la
dette par habitant ça va être à la fin
de l'année avec les 3000 milliards ça
sera 45000 euros bon alors vous allez
débattre c'est intéressant au moins on a
les positions j'ai une petite question à
la députée d'expérience que vous êtes
merci alors les amendements adoptés en
séance sont pas forcément en séance dans
l'hémicycle pas en commission retenue
par le gouvernement au moment du 49-3
c'est bien ça c'est bien ça ça veut dire
que le gouvernement décide au fond du
texte du texte qui veut présenter
bonsoir Jacques Grandin de l’éprevier
vous êtes un peu l'arbitre pour essayer
de comprendre quelque chose à budget
prévision de croissance sur lequel est
bâti ce budget pour 2023 1% alors que
l'INSEE j'ai vu ça récemment nous dit 0%
de croissance sur ce trimestre ce
dernier trimestre 2022 il est pas déjà
caduc ce budget le budget est optimiste
sur les prévisions de croissance enfin
le gouvernement nous a habitués à ça et
donc c'est vrai qu'il est assez
optimiste pour pour l'année prochaine
mais ça ça va impacter sur tous les
prévisions de déficit donc on peut
reprocher entre guillemets au
gouvernement de se baser sur des
prévisions un peu optimistes après moi
ce que je trouve intéressant sur le fond
du du budget c'est que les oppositions
se sont un peu tirées une balle dans le
pied enfin vous allez me dire si vous
pensez la même chose en disant dès le
départ avant même le débat sur le fond
qu'elle ne voudrait pas voter le budget
et donc le gouvernement et la majorité
utilisent cet argument pour dire vous
voyez elles se sont opposées avant même
le fond des débats et donc on peut
utiliser ça en disant bah nous on est
prêt à débattre et pas les oppositions
et là on a l'impression que les
oppositions essayent maintenant de
député du fond vous l'avez fait vous
l'avez fait également mais l'argument
que va essayer peut-être de reprendre la
majorité c'est de dire le fond de vous
intéresse pas puisque vous vous êtes la
posture était déjà posée
moi je tiens à rappeler à ce stade du
débat je n'ai pas été élu avec
l'étiquette Renaissance ou lrem moi j'ai
une autre étiquette donc il faut aussi
respecter ce que chacun moi je comprends
que les députés de la majorité ils vont
voter comme un seul homme c'est normal
d'ailleurs je note qu'ils sont quand
même un certain nombre d'amendements
mais qui vont tous retirer avant de les
avoir défendu ou alors les défendre les
retirer deuxième élément c'est que
aujourd'hui on a voté le PN FR2
l'opposition
qui permettait le bouclier justement
pour protéger la consommation des
Français dans une période de crise on
l'a voté en responsabilité j'ai aucun
problème avec le sujet de voter un
élément sauf que un projet de loi de
finance c'est quoi projet de loi de
finance c'est le premier du mandat de ce
quinquennat Emmanuel Macron du second
mandat Emmanuel Macron il va donner en
acte il va traduire en acte les la
politique qu'il veut qu'il souhaite et
je suis désolé il y a plein de mesures
que je ne peux pas soutenir donc la
réalité c'est que quel que soit ses
propositions un projet de loi de finance
rectificative oui parce qu'il protégeait
la consommation des ménages projets de
loi de finance tel qu'il est conçu
aujourd'hui sans
triste sérieuse de maintien de la
dépense de maîtrise de la dépense
publique ce que vous parlez de la
croissance si elle est pas au
rendez-vous et si on continue avec cette
dépense là telle qu'elle est programmée
possible
c'est ça le danger donc en
responsabilité on ne votera pas Thomas
Cazenave mais vous voyez un peu la
situation dans laquelle on est c'est que
d'un côté la nups nous dit ça budget
d'austérité alors même qu'on a 45
milliards d'euros pour protéger le
pouvoir d'achat des Français qu'on
augmente le budget de l'éducation un peu
plus de 3 milliards d'euros que l'on va
recruter des policiers supplémentaires
et de l'autre la droite nous dit vous
faites pas assez d'efforts et nous notre
conviction c'est que finalement la
position qui est la note le projet qui
le note c'est un projet d'équilibre et
sur lequel on est prêt à discuter mais
ça date d'équilibre c'est à la fois on
protège et on s'inscrit dans une
stratégie de redressement des finances
publiques 3% 2025 5% en 2023 judiciaire
des objectifs qui semblent difficiles à
atteindre certains budgets qui est plus
dépensier largement plus dépensé et la
conjoncture l'oblige par rapport à
l'année dernière l'exige et en même
temps 5% du PIB en un an ça semble
compliqué c'est vraiment tenable tout ça
en baissant les impôts des entreprises
c'est réaliste franchement c'est
l'équilibre de ce de ce budget en disant
on va faire des efforts par exemple
c'est les dépenses des ministères je
pense le ministère le ministère de le
ministère de l'Économie et des Finances
qui fait des efforts
mais on prépare l'avenir
merci mais avec l'éducation on fait un
effort considérable parce qu'on veut des
enseignants mieux rémunérés et on
demande y compris d'ailleurs aux
collectivités locales de faire un effort
tout le monde doit faire des efforts
pourquoi parce qu'on a besoin d'assurer
la soutenabilité nos finances publiques
donc
on ne peut pas justice on ne peut pas
reporter sur les générations futures ben
nos déficit d'aujourd'hui donc on doit
faire les deux c'est un peu cet
équilibre là qu'on essaie de construire
moi un nouveau je pense que c'est pas un
argument que de dire on est au milieu
donc ça veut dire qu'en fait on a raison
puisqu'on est dans l'équipe non ça veut
surtout dire que personne n'est d'accord
avec vous et à mon sens c'est que vous
devez revoir votre texte et si vous
voulez continuer avec un budget que moi
je juge d'austérité mais je pense que je
suis pas le seul il faudra trouver une
alliance avec nos collègues des
républicains mais arrêtez de jouer faux
jeu à dire qu'on est au milieu et aller
directement avec la droite et je vous
écoute juste sur un point juste sur un
point aussi tout à l'heure on a dit ils
ont dit qu'ils allaient pas voter ce
texte avant même que le texte sorte non
mais attendez c'est Emmanuel Macron
quand même ça fait 5 ans qu'on le
connaît enfin donc on avait déjà on
savait déjà à peu près ce qui allait
arriver dans ce texte la ligne était
toujours la même quand Elisabeth borne
vient l'Assemblée nationale à son
discours politique générale et dit 26
fois le verbe continuer excusez-moi il y
a assez peu de doutes donc vous savez
qu'ils allaient continuer
on le vote quand on est dans la majorité
on vote contre quand on est dans
l'opposition c'est une ligne politique
de tout temps depuis je pense le début
de la 5e République donc vous pouvez
rétorquer cet argument à la majorité
après tout vous êtes dans l'opposition
personne n'en doute moi si ce budget il
avait permis de je sais pas moi de
rénover tous nos bâtiments tous ne pas
sortir alors que là c'est pas du tout le
cas on devait faire 80 000 en 2021 on a
fait 2500 budget oui et ça fonctionne
vous savez que personne
mille entreprises dans ce pays qui font
du BTP il y en a 65000 formé à la
rénovation thermique est-ce qu'il y a un
budget pour que les entreprises se
forment davantage
6 milliards de plus sur le budget emploi
c'est pour former au nouveau métier 6
milliards de plus sur le budget emploi
dans ce budget pour la formation
je voudrais qu'on essaye d'avancer je
vous donne la parole j'adore dans un
mais ça m'intéresse de s'attarder un
instant sur vos votre position des
républicains puisque vous êtes
traditionnellement le groupe charnière
qui permet sur chaque texte d'avoir ou
non et on est force de propositions
Stéphanie Despierre vous suivez les
républicains à l'Assemblée nationale
elle est lisible cette stratégie sur le
budget à vos yeux ou pas pas toujours et
parfois pas très homogène Olivier
Marleix le patron des députés LR est
partisans d'une ligne d'urfos au pouvoir
et au budget il l'a dit déjà il y a
quelques semaines c'est un budget de
déraisonnable intenable trop de dépenses
le groupe les républicains votera donc
contre en commission la droite a réussi
avec le soutien de la gauche souvent à
faire adopter des amendements et abattre
le gouvernement sauf que dans cette loi
de finances il y a un certain nombre de
mesures défendues de longues dates par
les républicains comme par exemple la
baisse des impôts de production
notamment la CVAE le gouvernement veut
la supprimer d'ici deux ans sur cet
article là les républicains soutiendront
donc l'exécutif en déposant plus de
milliers d'amendements sur le budget les
députés LR démontrent aussi qu'ils
veulent peser sur le le texte final
s'ils sont entendus une poignée d'entre
eux pourrait même s'abstenir sur
l'ensemble du texte et donc ne pas
suivre la ligne de leur patron Olivier
Marleix quand on demande à des ténors du
groupe si vraiment tous les députés à
l'air voteront comme un seul homme il
sourit et s'exclame mais il n'y aura pas
de vote il y aura un 49,3 qui les
arrange donc bien pas de vote donc pas
de prise de position individuelle de
chaque député et donc pas d'éventuelles
divisions étaler au grand jour merci
beaucoup Stéphanie pour votre analyse 62
LR 62 voix distinctes non moi non il y a
que trois options pour voter vous avez
pour contre on a l'impression que ce
sont des individualités s'abstenir sur
le budget quand même c'est pas rien
quand on est dans l'opposition pour vous
je suis assez d'accord avec vous c'est
pour ça que je n'ai pas retenu cette
option ça nous a pas échappé donc voilà
mais après la liberté vous savez c'est
quelque chose de d'important non mais je
crois que la très grande majorité du
groupe sera
votre compte si on arrive au bout du
terme de cet examen mais alors il y a
peut-être deux ou trois exceptions je ne
sais pas mais
surprenant sur les baisses d'impôts
alors la CVAE c'est la
contributions
c'est un signal de poursuit la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron pour faciliter
l'investissement réduire la charge
fiscale des entreprises à la droite la
toujours réclamer non oui voilà je pense
c'est assez intéressant de regarder quel
a été la position de la droite sur toute
la question de la de la réduction de la
dépense publique et en fait ça fait
plusieurs mois que il y a un certain
flou qu'entretien aussi la majorité
volontairement sur la position de la
droite puisque cet été il y a eu des
débats au Parlement sur les mesures pour
pour l'année en cours et les les
parlementaires républicains avaient
défendu notamment des dépenses massives
qui consistaient à baisser le prix des
des carburants et donc à l'époque déjà
la majorité avait mis en avant le fait
que les républicains je voulais
augmenter la dépense publique qui avait
beaucoup vexé notamment le chef de fil
des députés républicains Olivier Marleix
et là on voit un peu la même séquence
qui risque de se reproduire cet automne
avec le gouvernement qui avait lancé une
plateforme de réduction des dépenses
publiques à laquelle on refusait de
participer les républicains de peur de
la récupération politique justement du
gouvernement en disant bah si on est
dans cette Task Force et on est sur des
mesures communes on va être associé à la
majorité donc les députés
compréhensibles ça par les Français
c'est une vraie question est-ce que
c'est compréhensible de cette peur de la
majorité quand attendez je finis
et en fait la récemment les républicains
ont fait de nouveau des propositions de
mesures pour ce budget de réduction
exactement et ce que ce que reproche la
majorité c'est que ça soit des mesures
trop floues et pas assez concrètes et là
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
les mêmes reproches qu'on fait à la
majorité au final les observateurs
extérieurs reprochent à la fois à la
majorité et pour ce qui est de la
dépense publique
puis ensuite on avance
on a travaillé sur deux organismes qui
ont sorti des documents intéressants les
frappe dit aujourd'hui que l'ensemble
des agences et des opérateurs de l'État
en central représente 100 milliards
d'euros de dépenses par an 100 milliards
l'OCDE qui est un organisme on va pas
contester les statistiques de l'OCDE
quand elle nous arrange bien la majorité
quand elles en ont bien la majorité elle
les reprend l'OCDE dit la France c'est
84 milliards d'euros par an
supplémentaires par la moyenne en
dépense en dépense dans le périmètre de
la dépense par rapport à l'ensemble des
pays de européen bon 84 milliards on est
parti on est parti d'un chiffre très bas
on fait un amendement pour une sobriété
bureaucratique vous savez l'ensemble des
agences qu'on a créé pendant 5 ans là le
gouvernement on a créé tout plein
du sport enfin on a rajouté un rapport
de la Cour des comptes très intéressant
sur ce sujet là d'ailleurs en parallèle
du ministère des Sports
c'est l'urgence aussi un slogan 20
milliards pas une piste concrète parce
que dans les opérateurs de l'État je
rappelle les universités les CROUS
l'hébergement des étudiants mais si vous
faites un raisonnement central
maintenant vous faites un raisonnement
global je vais prendre 20 milliards sur
les opérateurs sauf que les opérateurs
les plus importants ils ont des missions
d'ailleurs qui sont essentielles je
parlais des universités on peut parler
de l'université et donc le problème
c'est que dans vos 20 milliards vous
avez jamais dit exactement vous allez
les prendre donc vous avez fait un
raisonnement global donc c'est pas
crédible arrivé avec des propositions
concrètes et là honnêtement c'était un
peu par exemple vous vous êtes oui mais
alors très concrètement suffit pas de
dire dans les périmés des ministères au
bout d'un moment pour qu'on puisse
suivre parce que ce qui nous ils
aimeraient savoir s'il y a encore des
pistes de compromis possibles quand vous
entendez voilà une main tendue sur
trouver des économies dans les
opérateurs de l'État je comprends que
c'est pas l'université centrales il y a
ouverture possible ou les choses sont
faites bien sûr possible et les économie
les économies c'est pas un tabou mais
faut arriver à des propositions
concrètes pas juste se faire plaisir en
disant il y a 20 milliards à tout de
suite apprendre très facile je voudrais
vous montrer quand même une séquence
dans l'hémicycle de cet après-midi ça
n'a pas vraiment lié avec le budget mais
ça raconte un peu le climat dans lequel
ce budget va être débattu c'est une
passe d'armes qui s'est tenue en fin
d'après-midi à la fin des questions au
Gouvernement elle oppose un député du
rassemblement national Alexandre Loubet
qui a eu des mots fleuris qui a traité
de lâche le ministre du de la ministre
des Finances pardon Bruno Le Maire ça
lui a valu et de l'économie ça lui a
valu un rappel à l'ordre en bonne et due
forme regardez cet échange
Monsieur le Maire vous avez travaillé il
fut un temps pour Dominique de Villepin
qui avait dénoncé la lâcheté de ceux qui
refusent de défendre les intérêts de la
France aujourd'hui le lâche c'est vous
-même
j'ai l'honneur de demander des excuses
solennelles au rassemblement national
pour avoir employé le terme de lâche à
une personne qui a toujours fait preuve
de courage dans son engagement politique
depuis 20 ans qu'il fait de la politique
au service de la France et des Français
cette situation est proprement
inadmissible nous avons donc quitté
l'hémicycle pour rappeler à Monsieur le
Maire que nous sommes députés et qu'en
aucun cas il ne peut avoir à l'égard des
députés du rassemblement national une
posture menaçante comme il a cru pouvoir
le faire s'il n'est pas capable de
garder son sang-froid et bien qu'il
aille planter des fraises
bonsoir Frank alizio vous êtes députés
du rassemblement national merci d'avoir
patienté salle des quatre colonnes en
duplex merci à vous alors votre groupe a
insulté en tout cas aux yeux de la
présidente de l'Assemblée qui avait les
yeux rivés sur son règlement insulter
Bruno Le Maire et puis même dans la
foulée papendi qui a été traitée de
communautariste dans l'hémicycle est-ce
que la normalisation c'est fini au RN
pour considérer que lâche n'est pas une
insulte et que communautariste n'est pas
une insulte c'est une caractéristique ce
n'est pas agréable mais c'est pas une
insulte donc je rappelle que David
normalement traditionnellement dans une
enceinte parlementaire la liberté de
parole et sacrée elle est plus protégée
que à l'extérieur d'une enceinte
justement pour protéger l'opposition
pour laisser cette fonction stigmatisée
mais évidemment enfin Monsieur le Maire
est visiblement déjà fatigué par cette
début d’examen du budget il a pas eu
sans emploi quant à Monsieur papenza il
est tout simplement pas habitué aux
joues toratoires pas habitué à
l'enceinte parlementaire tout simplement
mais depuis qui peut considérer que
communautariste et lâche c'est une
insulte et ça et ça mérite une sanction
c'est c'est hallucinant hallucinant
revenons au budget puisque c'est le
thème de notre débat ce soir j'ai cru
comprendre que vous étiez prêt à signer
la motion de censure si elle est déposée
par la France insoumise en cas de 49-3
c'est bien ça
on est tout simplement prêt à signer une
éventuelle motion qui répondrait à
l'usage d'un 49-3 donc un passage en
force de l'exécutif sur un texte aussi
essentiel aussi sacré que la loi de
finance et le budget qui est par
excellence ce qui doit être voté à
l'assemblée donc oui évidemment il
faudrait que la motion de censure soit
écrite dans des termes neutres et pas
dans une logorrhée d'extrême gauche
merci beaucoup Franck alizio d'avoir été
en duplex dans cette émission pour nous
Damien Audet une motion de censure dans
des termes neutres qui viendraient mêler
les voix des insoumis au rassemblements
national pas de problème franchement
nous on fera notre notre motion de
censure avec avec la nuit Pesse et on
n'a pas de jugement à avoir sur les
termes que nous allons utiliser tout ça
pour pour plaire
au rassemblement de la posture tout ça
parce qu'il faut bien quand même si vous
voulez vraiment renverser le
gouvernement par une censure obtenir une
majorité de votes sur cette censure donc
ça va être comme ça jusqu'à la fin de la
dictature nous voici ceci on a été élu
donc on va faire la motion de censure va
répondre aussi aux exigences qui ont eu
nos électeurs et c'est à dire qu'on va
l'écrire dans nos termes il y a pas à
avoir les fameux terme neutres en plus
lequel le collègue d'extrême droite qui
dit qu'il nous dit après en plus des
termes d'extrême gauche ou quoi donc on
a pas à obéir aux demandes du
rassemblement national sur la motion de
censure par contre quoi qu'il en soit
nous effectivement on en déposera une
parce que on pense que c'est important
s'il y a 40 ans et passage en force il
doit y avoir une réponse j'aimerais
quand même que vous nous donniez un peu
votre regard sur le climat dans lequel
on est entre pays je vous donnerai le
mot de la fin Jacques Grandin Thomas
Cazenave moi je vais vous dire je
voudrais revenir cet épisode parce que
j'ai été profondément choqué moi c'est
mon premier mandat vous le disiez en
introduction j'étais dans l'hémicycle et
cette insulte à l'endroit de de Bruno Le
Maire je trouve ça redonne le vrai
visage du rassemblement national qui
s'est jamais véritablement banalisée et
je trouve qu'on doit respecter les
institutions et celles et ceux qui qui
siègent ou qui viennent qui
interviennent au sein de au sein de
l'assemblée est quand même pour redire
au-delà du climat ça ne serait pas la
première fois que les des oppositions se
mélangent
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment choquant
après on est moi je porte pas du tout
les mêmes valeurs ni que la France
insoumise ou
les écologistes ou
leur rassemblement national c'est
évident mais pas non plus les mêmes
valeurs que vous mais sur certains
sujets on peut avoir des regards approx
enfin vous pouvez voter ensemble au
gouvernement en commission des finances
la semaine dernière ça c'est fait mais
vous étiez d'ailleurs la majorité était
très contente quand où le RN ou la nups
votée avec vous parce que ça permet
effectivement vous voulez LR mais ça
permettait d'avoir une majorité je crois
qu'on peut pas faire de démagogie on va
pas sur le budget global on aura une
position claire moi je voterai contre
mais après sur certains amendements tout
s'étudie au cas par cas très clair le
débat but du terme commence on parle
souvent de Marathon tout ça sera écourté
votre expertise par 49-3 qui qui viendra
tel un coup près courser les débats
c'est assez clair que le 49-3 arrivera
bientôt et tout l'enjeu c'est de voir
que est-ce qu'on va réussir à débattre
du fond dans un contexte économique
explosif avec des risques de récession
et est-ce que les oppositions vont
rentrer dans le cadre très contraint
qu'à 1000 le gouvernement avec pas de
nouvelles dépenses et à la fin c'est lui
qui tranche merci beaucoup le problème
de la pénurie des carburants
5 sur le la CVAE va risquer de l'amener
de beaucoup de débats il y a un
amendement du Gouvernement aussi sur sur
une contribution des pétroliers on y
revient c'est évident soit après soi
parce que c'est ce qui occupe les
députés dans l'hémicycle pour de longues
semaines merci beaucoup merci à vous
d'avoir participé à ce débat on va
présent accueillir notre grand témoin
elle est grande reporter c'est l'une des
plus belles plumes du journal Le Monde
passionnée de politique elle a ouvert le
champ de ses enquêtes depuis quelques
années aux grandes personnalités de
notre temps et dans son dernier livre
co-écrit avec Vanessa Schneider elle
nous raconte les secrets des plus grands
entrepreneurs français ça s'appelle
succession l'argent le sang et les
larmes tout un programme chez Albin
Michel Rafael baquet nous rejoint juste
après l'invitation signé ce soir Clément
Méric
si on vous invite Raphaël baquet c'est
pour nous parler d'un sujet tabou chez
les grandes fortunes de France
Bolloré Lagardère Arnaud comment les
capitaines d'industrie préparent-ils
leur succession cette question aura fait
le baquet vous en avez fait le thème de
votre dernier livre succession que vous
consignez avec votre collègue Vanessa
Schneider tout ça va l'immortel c'est et
c'est vrai que préparer sa succession ça
veut dire préparer un jour son départ sa
mort donc c'est pas quelque chose qui
est aisé à faire grand reporter au monde
sous votre plume vos personnages qu'il
s'agisse de Karl Lagerfeld destroscan ou
de Ségolène Royal deviennent de simples
humains avec leurs rêves et leurs
blessures intimes dans succession on
découvre ainsi Jérôme Seydoux 8 enfants
et aucun qui ne mérite à ses yeux de lui
succéder à l'opposé Jean-Luc Lagardère
le père a tout fait pour transmettre le
flambeau à son fils unique quitte à
mettre un peu la pression sur le fiston
Arnaud c'est mon fils et s'il m'arrive
quoi que ce soit il suivra cet
engagement qui est lui aussi jusqu'à sa
fin de poursuivre l'indépendance et le
développement de Matra résultat une
succession catastrophique qui fait
figure de contre-exemples absolus quand
il meurt effectivement son fils a déjà
40 ans bien sonné on l'appelle encore
junior et il ne réussira jamais à égaler
son père et finalement il va choisir de
le détruire le fils a finalement
démantelé l'empire du père pour le
livrer à un de ses adversaires Freud
aurait été adoré parfois le patriarche
change d'avis en cours de route chez les
Bouygues Francis avaient l'embarras du
choix son fils Nicolas directeur général
de la division BTP sa fille Corinne son
attachée de presse son
Olivier l'homme de la diversification
Martin le benjamin et le président de
maison Bouygues le père a d'abord choisi
Nicolas avant de lui préférer Martin ce
fils là je trouve que il a toutes les
qualités d'un entrepreneur
ce fils là avait surtout le mérite de ne
pas vouloir tout chambouler dans
l'entreprise autant d'histoires que de
personnages donc mais s'il y avait un
fil rouge un point commun à toutes ces
grandes fortunes de France Raphaël
baquet quel serait-il
bonsoir Raphaël baquet et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct sur ce
plateau sur la Chaîne Parlementaire
alors pour répondre au-delà de l'argent
évidemment le fil rouge entre toutes ces
personnalités c'est patriarches c'est
succession c'est quoi en fait c'est que
leurs histoires de famille ressemblent
aux autres c'est des histoires de
d'enfants préférés de rivalité entre
frère de père qui ne supporte pas de
laisser la place et c'est ça qui nous a
plu dans toutes ces histoires c'est ce
que dit votre porteur c'est Freud au
sein du grand capitalisme au fond et
c'est pas une histoire d'argent c'est
une histoire d'affect beaucoup le
psychologique déterminant comment vous
avez réussi à mener cette enquête ce
sont des familles extrêmement fermées
qui n'aiment pas du tout être dans la
lumière comment vous vous avez procédé
vous prenez par cercle concentrique du
plus large au plus serré comment ça se
passe
d'abord on a mis parfois beaucoup de
temps allez convaincre de nous recevoir
et tous n'ont pas accepter mais par
exemple Bernard Arnault a mis 3 ans
avant d'accepter de l'éducation de ces
enfants tout simplement c'est vrai que
ce sont des patrons qui ont qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de parler de même il
parle de leur business de leur
entreprise mais surtout pas d'eux et
alors encore moins de leur secret de
famille ils ont une armada d'avocat des
conseillers en communication donc mais
autour d'eux d'abord ils ont souvent une
cour aussi des des directeurs des des
barons des des dirigeants de
l'entreprise qui les connaissent mieux
que personne ils connaissent la famille
et donc entre les sources internes si on
peut dire de l'entreprise et puis même
lorsqu'ils ont accepté de nous parler on
a réussi à sécher très très largement de
la réalité la succession pour tous ces
hommes c'est une obsession et en même
temps c'est quasiment impossible
sans Bolloré raconte pratiquement à tout
le monde que sur sa montre il y a un
compte à rebours d'ailleurs il l'a
dépassé c'était toujours là voilà 70 ans
il avait dit qu'il partirait il est
toujours là ils peuvent pas lâcher le
pouvoir en fait ils essayent d'organiser
des choses mais tant qu'ils sont pas
morts ils restent là la plupart d'entre
eux oui n'arrive pas à lâcher le pouvoir
et quand il le lâche ça peut être très
difficile François Pinault nous a
raconté par exemple la dépression qu'il
a traversé alors même qu'il avait tout
organisé pour lâcher les rênes à son
offre
qui s'appelait François comme lui et
puis il a eu du mal à accepter ça que le
téléphone ne sonne plus ce sont des
hommes qui sont incroyablement
sollicités quand ils ont construit
eux-mêmes leur empire voir un autre
dirigé à leur place ça peut être
extrêmement douloureux et celui qui est
choisi n'est pas forcément celui qui a
le plus de talent ça raconte ça aussi
hein ça raconte ça faut trop d'ombre
pour être héritier pour être choisi ça
raconte parfois la préférence la
projection que le patriarche accomplit
dans ses enfants et parfois
effectivement comme comme Francis
Bouygues par exemple ou comme chez les
gallimards ont choisi un enfant et puis
le fait que cet enfant prenne trop
autonomie et finalement vous remplace
trop bien ça devient insupportable et là
on a qu'une hâte c'est de l'écarter
alors Jérôme Seydoux de pâté faut
rappeler que c'est une série d'été sur
deux été qu'on a pu découvrir et qui
sont rassembler avec une introduction
bien sûr dans dans ce livre chaîne Albin
Michel que vous avez largement enrichi
c'est le plus diabolique pour moi Jérôme
Seydoux donc le cinéma les cinémas Pathé
c'est celui qui ne veut pas en fait
qu'on lui succède il écarte en un c'est
8 enfants et en fait il fait tout pour
que aucun de ces dauphins potentiels ne
puissent parvenir au pouvoir raconter
nous c'est vrai que ça pourrait faire un
formidable scénario de film lui dont la
spécialité le cinéma mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a une série de répétitions il a
des enfants d'un premier mariage puis
l'humain est un héritier au départ il
est de la famille Schlumberger et il
voudrait à vrai dire diriger le groupe
jemeberger et puis il était écarté il y
a une blessure et d'originelle la
famille a choisi un directeur général
qui n'est pas en son sein un homme très
compétent Jean rebou et j'aurais
beaucoup considère que finalement Jérôme
Seydou n'est pas compétent donc il
l'écarte et la famille est d'accord avec
ça ça c'est une blessure originelle qui
ne va avoir de 16 que devant de la
venger d'abord il va au fond divorcer
pour épouser la belle fille de celui qui
l'a écarté
Sophie qui était mariée avec Christophe
Reboul le fils de Jean rebou femme de
son frère
la femme la femme du fils de celui qui
l'a écarté c'est vraiment déjà un
premier problème et son ex excusez-moi
à cause de ça c'est vraiment très grave
ce qui se passe et effectivement il
adopte ses enfants donc il se crée au
fond des héritiers supplémentaires il en
a 8 vous l'avez dit et personne n'est à
la hauteur à ses yeux et finalement non
seulement il écarte ses propres enfants
de la succession mais il écarte aussi
les directeurs généraux qu'ils se
choisit c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'il y en a qui pourrait le remplacer
tout d'un coup une dimension tragédie
grecque parce que pour Jérôme Sedo donc
c'est effectivement la femme de son
meilleur ami qui décède qu'il va épouser
pour Vincent Bolloré et là c'est bien ça
c'est la femme de son frère la femme de
sa sœur la fameuse de sa femme pardon
c'est sa belle-sœur je vais y arriver
les divorces c'est très important dans
ces affaires mais qu'est-ce que c'est
sanglant mais ça détruit toutes les
familles déjà dans la vie réelle c'est
difficile un divorce mais lorsqu'il y a
un enjeu industriel et un enjeu de
pouvoir ça crée la complications
supplémentaire parce que en plus si vous
avez des enfants de deux mariages
différents il faut organiser leur
entente car le poison de la rivalité si
vous voulez peut-être catastrophique
dans un groupe industriel et ça
effectivement c'est ce que traverse
Vincent Bolloré c'est ce que vont
travailler aussi Bernard Arnault font
Sapino au fond il ressemble à chacun
d'entre nous dans des cadres qui ne
ressemble pas au nôtres évidemment quel
diriez-vous de ce qu'on a cité Pinot
Bouygues Arnaud Bolloré Seydoux lequel a
au fond la volonté de puissance sans
limite la plus la plus extravagante
beaucoup d'entre eux Vincent Bolloré
être un certainement il a quatre enfants
il en a choisi deux il les a façonnés à
son image il ne cesse de dire que il
leur laisse la main et puis il la laisse
pas
Bernard Arnault qui
entraîne qui élève c'est 5 enfants comme
on entraîne des chevaux de course qu'il
les mettent tous sur la ligne de départ
qui qui étudie très minutieusement leurs
compétences qu'il est vraiment qu'il est
dresse
vérifier là où va l'argent qui demande
des notes de frais alors à ses propres
enfants plein d'entre eux n'a échappé à
son désir de les voir dans le groupe il
est impossible d'avoir des des rebelles
dans ces familles c'est d'ailleurs très
intéressant de voir que très souvent on
n'échappe pas la volonté du Père elle
vous rattrape elle vous rattrape alors
il y a d'autres familles les milliers
par exemple la grande famili
industrielle du Nord beaucoup plus
discrète tu n'aimes pas du tout
démontrer l'argent pas ostentatoire du
tout contrairement on apprend ça à
de Lagardère qui a vécu dans l'opulence
qui n'a connu que les jets privés je
voulais vous montrer cette image donc
que des hommes quand même alors on n'a
pas mis Liliane bédancourt parce que
c'est une héritière et elle n'a jamais
été aux commandes
on est on est dans la figure du
capitaine d'industrie dit à 25 ans
c'était impossible autrement que des
hommes mais c'est vrai malheureusement
on a trouvé dans tous ces grands groupes
industriels vous le voyez bien
aujourd'hui il n'y a que trois femmes
dans le CAC 40 et elles ne sont pas les
actionnaires elles ne sont pas les
détentrices du capital elles ont été
choisies par les entreprises donc c'est
vrai que dans ces entreprises familiales
pour l'instant il y a essentiellement
des hommes ça va changer Antoine
Gallimard à quatre filles donc il va
choisir parmi elles il y a des femmes
qui qui arrivent François Henri Pino
aussi a des filles donc elles sont elles
sont là mais jusque là effectivement
c'est sans aucun doute une question
d'époque hélas mais ces hommes ne
pensaient pas leur fille François
Pinault a une fille aînée il n'a jamais
il le dit lui-même je n'ai même pas
songé qu'elle puisse prendre les
commandes très rapidement il nous reste
une poignée de secondes il vous
intéresse encore nos politiques parce
que quand on regarde vos livres on s'en
éloigne là c'est les capitaines
d'industrie c'était qu'à la
leur attribution c'est un sujet très
très politique alors déjà pour rappeler
pour noter les spectateurs ce sont des
groupes d'amitié qui rassemblent des
députés de tout bord pour nous des liens
avec des élus d'autres pays il y en a
presque pour tous les pays qu'ils soient
démocratique ou pas ça n'est pas un
soutien politique à un régime en
particulier plutôt des échanges
informels entre les délégations c'est de
la diplomatie parlementaire c'est la
vice-présidente Valérie rabot qui a la
lourde tâche de les constituer d'ici au
mois de décembre et c'est vrai que
certains groupes et ben c'est ça va pas
être simple de de les constituer de les
former alors pourquoi ça fait débat
parce que ces groupes même si n'ont
aucun pouvoir ce sont des vitrines et
l'irruption de 89 députés rassemblement
national fait que mécaniquement ils vont
présider une petite vingtaine de groupes
d'amitié et ça c'est évidemment inédit
le RN vise par exemple la présidence du
groupe amitié France Maroc ou France
Israël évidemment des groupes
extrêmement symboliques qui marqueront
une étape de plus dans la normalisation
de l'extrême droite au Parlement et
évidemment ça fait grincer les dents
mais c'est la règle donc elle s'applique
et d'autres groupes qui posent problème
il y un très gros morceau le désormais
très encombrant groupe d'amitié France
Russie ça fait des mois qu'il est sur
pause lors de la précédente législature
la présidence la macroniste Caroline
janvier c'était mise en retrait après
l'invasion russe en Ukraine c'est quand
même très délicat comment dialoguer avec
les députés de la Douma à Moscou quand
ces derniers soutiennent évidemment
cette guerre absolument sanglante donc
imagine qu'il y a pas grand monde pour
le représenter ce groupe mais non
imaginez quel député quelle famille
politique aurait envie d'être affublé
actuellement du tampon président du
groupe d'amitié France Russie comment
comment l'opinion est surtout les
électeurs le comprendrais sauf que sur
le papier en fait il y a aucune raison
que ce groupe disparaisse pour avoir un
groupe d'amitié il faut il y a trois
choses il faut qu'il y ait un parlement
dans le pays il faut qu'il y a une
ambassade en France et il faut que le
pays soit membre de l'ONU évidemment la
Russie elle coche toutes les cases à
partir du moment où ça n'est pas un
soutien politique pourquoi traiter
différemment la Russie du Yémen ou
peut-être de la Chine alors peut-être
que le problème il réside dans dans le
nom amitié et ben en fait c'est ça le
problème et c'est c'est là que c'est
finalement assez drôle ça peut prêter à
confusion me glisser un député membre de
du groupe russe une des solutions serait
donc de peut-être dégrader le statut du
groupe je sais que Vincent connait bien
ces questions là il part il passerait de
groupe d'amitié à groupe d'études à
vocation internationales sachez qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est ce qui est
réservé pour des pays comme la Corée du
Nord la Libye ou encore la Syrie
certains disent attention quand même un
jour ou l'autre il faudra préparer
l'après et ce serait quand même
intéressant de ne pas totalement scout
se couper de la Russie merci beaucoup
c'est vrai qu'ils sont importants ces
groupes d'amitié parce que moi je me
souviens d'un certain Didier Julia qui
avait fait une expédition vous vous
souvenez en Syrie et il était au fond à
la tête de ce groupe d'amitié il avait
tissé des liens donc il faut pas en
négliger leur importance Raphaël bien
sûr ou le groupe franco-chinois
Jean-Pierre Raffarin il a fait
merci de ce petit rappel bonsoir Yanis
alors nouvelle histoire d'école je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire en Seine-Saint-Denis vous je
vais aborder avec vos élèves la semaine
dernière la révolte anti voile en Iran à
partir d'une image qui a fait le tour
des réseaux sociaux oui des lycéennes
qui pointent un doigt d'honneur en
direction d'Alli ramené il actuel guide
suprême de la Révolution islamique et de
Romani l'ancien guide de la révolution
l'image choc que je leur ai montré et
j'avoue que j'étais un peu surpris ils
n'ont pas du tout suréagi ils ont décrit
la photo en notant quand même le geste
bien sûr mais sans jugement il faut dire
que ces mots là sont chiites et que ça
leur parle pas trop
la discussion à la suite de cette image
s'est engagé avec les élèves alors
comment s'est-elle passée cette
discussion compliquée ou pas
quand on discute avec les années il faut
toujours faire attention à ce qu'on dit
et comment on le dit en rappelant
d'emblée que le professeur n'a pas à
prendre position sur des questions
d'ordre religieux et dans ces cas-là ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on constate
toujours que les élèves veulent parler
de ces sujets donc les questions elles
ont fusées
des questions elles sont venues au fur
et à mesure en fait de la discussion
mais tout de suite ils ont voulu le
ramener le sujet à ce qu'il les touche
au quotidien ils m'ont bien sûr demandé
pourquoi l'Iran avait rendu le voile
obligatoire mais aussi pourquoi en
France certains contestent la
possibilité de porter le porter en fait
alors que c'est la liberté de chacun
existe-t-il mais élèves de 3e pose en
fait le débat de la manière de certains
politiques qui disent la liberté ici la
liberté là-bas ok mais une fois qu'on a
rappelé ça
il faut dire que le voile est uniquement
interdit à l'école en France et que il
faut rester le plus neutre possible tout
en rappelant d'ailleurs notre
attachement commun aux valeurs de
liberté et d'égalité et alors qu'est-ce
que ça donne
on leur retourne la question en réalité
on leur dit voilà savoir est-ce que
selon eux ce que sous-tend en fait
l'obligation du port du voile en Iran et
ils finissent par vous le dire ils
disent voilà la femme doit cacher ses
cheveux pour ne pas provoquer les hommes
il vous disent en réalité ce qu'ils
entendent ici
votre rôle c'est aussi quand on est prof
de les faire réfléchir et vous leur
demandez si les hommes eux sont
susceptibles d'aguicher les femmes en
général ça les fait plutôt marrer mais
pour faire que pour leur faire
comprendre ce que signifie ce qu'ils
disent je leur ai fait lire et commenter
les propos de l'actrice française
d'origine iranienne elle a quitté l'Iran
en 2008
gold shiftée Farahani qu'elle a tenu
dans le monde l'autre jour le 9 octobre
et elle dit toute ma vie en Iran j'ai
détesté être une femme car une femme en
Iran est coupable coupable de ses seins
de ses cheveux de ses formes coupables
si on la regarde coupable si on la
touche coupable si on l'agresse une
élève a réagi en disant que la femme n'a
pas à être coupable d'être une femme je
me suis permis d'ajouter
les légales de l'homme mais aussi que
personne n'interdit de porter le voile
grâce à la liberté de conscience de la
liberté de culte deux piliers de la
laïcité
vos élèves elle vient systématiquement
c'est cette idée que en France on fait
une fixette sur le voile alors il peut
évidemment y avoir une dimension à une
dimension
xénophobe mais on doit aussi leur
expliquer qu'il y a aussi des gens que
cela dérange pour les mêmes raisons
qu'avant ce gold shifter pharaoni et
quand bien même porter un voile serait
un choix pour ces gens cela n'enlève
rien au modèle de société auquel le
voile renvoie c'est à dire le modèle
le même modèle que celui des molles
sujet complexe donc à aborder en classe
sur le fond comme sur la forme mais fait
réfléchir et parfois contre soi-même
n'est-ce pas le rôle de l'école mais
c'est le vôtre en tout premier lieu et
merci de le l'utiliser à plein ce rôle
d'enseignant penser contre soi-même
Rafael bac et vous qui avez enseigné
enquêter plutôt attrape on se souvient
de
sujets
même explosif c'est vrai que on voit
bien malgré la loi de 2004 ça reste un
sujet y compris sur la volonté de le
réintroduire à l'école mais vous avez
raison d'en parler comme ça je trouve
que c'est intéressant d'aborder la
symbolique les conséquences politiques
dans certains pays et c'est très
intéressant de faire réfléchir les
élèves sur ce sujet et sur les
Iraniennes vous avez l'impression que
nos politiques ont pris la mesure de ce
qui s'y passait et sont au côté de ces
femmes et de tout le peuple iranien
maintenant qui dans tout le pays quel
que soit les générations les classes
sociales s'oppose au régime c'est
difficile de pas être de tout cœur avec
elle quand même ce pourra pas vous
citiez l’interview de golfister farani
elle raconte aussi ce que comme ça pesé
sur toute sa génération elle dit dans ma
génération on était 25 en conservatoire
il n'y en a que 5 qui ont eu des enfants
ça a vraiment pesé sur leur vie
personnelle et je pense que
effectivement cette espèce de chatte de
plomb d'obligation de négation de ce que
la liberté des femmes comme telles qu'on
la vie et qu'on a la chance de la vivre
nous effectivement ça peut vraiment être
un vrai verrou pour beaucoup d'individus
alors on reste on va dire sur la
question internationale de l'Iran à la
Biélorussie la Biélorussie
deviendrait-elle au fond un allié mais
cette fois-ci sur le terrain de Poutine
va-t-elle entrer en guerre contre
l'Ukraine et bien longtemps le dictateur
biélorus Alexandre Lukachenko a incarné
une figure de style l'éprouvée de la
chronique parlementaire le soutien sans
participation offrir des gages de
loyauté à son impérieux paravent
Vladimir Poutine
muet son territoire en base arrière de
l'agression russe sur l'Ukraine qu'il
s'agisse de l'offensive avortée sur Kiev
des décollages de chasseurs bombardiers
sous koï ou des rafales de missiles
comment agir autrement lorsque l'on doit
au Kremlin le sauvetage d'un trône
chancelant c'est que réélu à l'été 2020
au prix d'une mascarade d'anthologie le
féal ou cachenko et sans doute été
balayé par une rébellion populaire sans
ces tuteurs moscovites mais voilà ce
despote aussi moustachu kanachronique
jadis directeur d'une ferme d'État
soviétique jusqu'à leur rechigné à
engager directement ses forces dans
l'aventure coloniale coutinienne
dont témoigne le déluge de fer et de feu
souvent aveugle infligé hier à une
vingtaine de villes ukrainiennes réduit
encore une marge de manœuvre étriquée
les serments fraternel la complicité ne
suffisent plus Poutine résolu à rouvrir
un front nord davantage et vite comme La
Teste divers indices a commencé par des
travaux engagés sur tel ou tel base
militaire biélorus hypothèse avancée par
les services de renseignement
occidentaux Moscou entravé par cette
pénurie patente de sous-officier
souhaite confier à des instructeurs
locaux la mise à niveau d'un contingent
de réserviste mobilisés comme on le sait
à grand peine on a l'impression à vous
entendre que les Biélorusses n'ont pas
vraiment le choix il y a un détail
éloquent vient de hausser Samir
rhétorique il accuse désormais la
Pologne la Lituanie et l'Ukraine dourdir
à son encontre des attaques terroristes
je le cite et devraient un soulèvement
d'où l'annonce du déploiement prochain
d'un groupement militaire régional Russo
biélorusses où ça quand quel effectifs
quelle mission qu'elle Arsenal mystère
d'ailleurs c'est une force purement
défensive à tenue à nuancer Minsk ce
midi peut-être le satrave va s'aliser
coincé entre une hiérarchie galonnée
russophile et une opinion réfractaire
espérant encore éviter de plonger ses
troupes dans une équipe et à l'issue à
certaines sont réquisitoire trahit aussi
une et surtout une hantise une hantise
récurrente celle d'une insurrection
fatale à son emprise scénario moins
chimérique qu'il n'y paraît malgré la
brutalité de l'appareil répressif les
figures de proue de l'opposition
biélorus ils sont d'ailleurs réduites à
choisir entre l'exil et la prison
refuse de courber l'échine citons nos
Cailla qui aux a défié dans les urnes
lucaschenko le fraudeur l'avocate Maria
collesnikova qui a été condamné en
septembre 2021 à 11 ans de tôle et bien
sûr bien sûr à l'aise beliatski coloréa
la semaine dernière du Nobel de la Paix
distinction très clairement hors de
portée du proconsul de minscris peu au
mieux briguer pour l'ensemble de son
œuvre à un Oscar de la servilité merci
merci beaucoup Vincent quelle plume et
merci de nous avoir cité ces dissidentes
ces opposantes biélorusses souvent
méconnues vous suivez de près même si
c'est pas votre terrain le conflit les
Ukrainiens
des crises c'est à dire quand un enfant
un autocrate comme lève Vladimir Poutine
part dans une fuite en avant aussi
délirante enfin en tout cas dangereuse
et tragique les vassaux les obliger la
cour les oligarques sont obligés de
suivre avec terreur parce qu'il se
demande jusqu'à quand ils vont devoir
suivre évidemment la folie du tyran et
ça c'est c'est passionnant à observer à
vrai dire dans l'histoire on l'a déjà vu
ce produit en mille fois passionnant et
terrifiant merci les affranchis merci
pour vos parties pris et l'idée
succession l'argent le sang et les
larmes co-écrit Raphaël baquet Vanessa
Schneider aux éditions Albin Michel
autre soirée documentaire commence
bientôt maintenant avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien bien sûr très belle soirée à
demain même le même heure
[Musique]